hello i will now explain to you what
hypotheses and hypothesis tests are
a hypothesis is an assumption or an
assumption about a connection for
example your hypothesis could be
men in germany earn
more than women in the same job
his goal is now to
either reject this hypothesis or to keep it
checking whether you
reject or maintain your hypothesis is done with the
help of existing data and
to check a hypothesis you could, for
example, have carried out a survey among 1000
employees in
Germany the analysis of your data is
now done with the help of a hypothesis test
in this case you would  e.g. use the test
for independent
samples abstract the hypothesis is what you
want to test to test the hypothesis
you need a suitable
hypothesis test and data there was one
thing i wasn't quite accurate on
this but before i get to that i'll explain to
you were you  a
hyp  you need
a hypothesis test whenever you want
to use a sample to prove or say something about the
population
is
therefore you have a population that
you want to examine as part of your work,
e.g. all working men and
women from Germany
because it is now not possible  all
working men and women are to be
surveyed you use a sample
from the total population if you
describe this sample only
you use descriptive statistics such
as the mean value or the
standard deviation but you want to make
a statement about the total population
so you use your
sample and with  with the help of a
hypothesis test you want to make a
statement about the population
so the goal of a hypothesis test is
to check hypotheses about the population using random samples
in short you have a random sample and
with the help of this  sample and the
appropriate hypothesis test you
want to check a statement about the population
, for example whether there is a difference in the salary
of men and women
but before you can calculate a hypothesis test
you have to make
sure that your hypothesis is also correctly
formulated we will come to that  now
when formulating hypotheses
, two hypotheses are always put forward
these two hypotheses claim exactly
the opposite these two
hypotheses are called 0 and alternative
hypotheses
the null hypothesis assumes that
there is no difference between two or more
groups, for example the
salary of men and women
does not differ in germany
the alternative hypothesis, on the other hand,
assumes that there is a difference
between two or more groups,
for example the salary of men and
women differs in germany
the new hypothesis is also abbreviated to trade
and the  alternative hypothesis
with h1 therefore the zero and the alternative
hypothesis always claim exactly the
opposite usually the
new hypothesis assumes that there is no
difference and the alternative
hypothesis assumes that there is a
difference it is important to note
that it is always zero  Hypotheses are tested with a
hypotheses test, so
the null hypothesis is always either
retained or rejected. Furthermore
, there are certain types of
hypotheses so that you
can formulate your hypotheses and find the right
test. It is important that you
know these types. The hypotheses are
differentiated between
and related hypotheses as well as directed and related
hypotheses so on the one hand
we have the distinction
difference and related hypothesis
and on the other hand directed and
undirected about thesis we start with
the difference and related
hypotheses different  ed on theses check
whether there is a difference between two
or more groups, for example
the group of men earns more than
the group of women or smokers
have a higher risk of heart attack than
non-smokers, so we have
the group of smokers and the
group of non-smokers in
exactly the same way  as we have the group of
men and the group of women up here,
therefore, with the difference to the thesis, it is
always checked whether there is a difference
between two or more groups,
so there is a categorical variable,
e.g. gender with male and female
or smoking status  with smoker
non-smoker and at least one original
escalated variable, e.g. the salary or
the risk of heart attack and percentage
more hp a
car has the higher the consumption
so in this case we check whether there is
a connection or a
correlation between variables have connection
hypotheses hopes the
shape the more the higher or lower
in short form difference hypotheses
check whether there is a difference between
two or  several groups are
related hypotheses check whether there is
a connection or a correlation
between variables this brings us
to the second way of distinguishing hypotheses
namely established and
undirected hypotheses established
hypotheses check whether there is a connection
or a difference
whereby it is legal in which direction
This connection or the
difference goes, for example, there is
a difference between the salary
of men and women but it does
not say whether the salary of men is
greater than the salary of women or there
is a connection between
height and  weight but he
doesn't say that we're taller than that so that our
weight is bigger
he just said there is a connection
but not in which
direction it is
opposite the directed
hypothesis the directed hypothesis also
indicates the direction of the connection
or the difference  for
example men earn more than
women or the more hp a car has,
the higher the consumption so on
the one hand we have the
targeted hypotheses that
simply provide information on whether there is a
difference or a connection
or not
on the other hand  we the
directed hypotheses, which
also indicate a direction
and now we come to the next
important point which hypothesis test
do you need in order to be allowed to write your
hypotheses
so which hypothesis test
do you need you have now formulated your thesis
and have drawn a random sample
from
this data  the sample you want
you now check for
this you have to select a suitable
hypothesis test and then of
course then
interpret
the results the question is now what is the suitable
hypothesis test and how can i
interpret the results
for the selection of the suitable hypothesis
test i only have three tips for you
first of all go to data
web.de and copy your data into the table on
data if you then
select the variables that you
want to analyze, datatec will already give
you a hint which the appropriate tests are
for more detailed information visitors
simply date up
de further  I have listed
the most common tests for you in the video description
I can highly recommend
daniela keller’s statistics starter
pack you can also find the link
in the video description so after
this video just take a look
at the video
description we now come to the  next
important point of interpretation d  he
results for the interpretation of the
results it is very important to
understand that every hypothesis test
always has a certain
probability of error you can
only determine with a hypothesis test with
a certain probability of error
whether a
hypothesis is accepted or rejected
why we say you have yours
basic population from this
basic population you have simply
taken two samples, sample 1
and sample 2 now it is completely
paralyzed
that sample 1 differs from sample
2 therefore on the basis of each
sample slightly
different statements are made about the
basic population
in the worst case you see a
random sample  which happens to be very different from
the
population as a whole. this can lead to you making a false statement
. hypotheses can therefore only
be accepted or
rejected with a certain probability of error so that everyone knows how
likely it is to be wrong  the statement is used
for p value the p value is the
probability of the observed
result plus even more extreme results
if the hypothesis was null this
sounds a bit complicated now
let's take a quick look at
our example
so you want to investigate if there is a
difference  between the salary of
men and women therefore give your total population
are all employed
women and men first of all
we assume that there is
no difference in salary between women and men
so we initially assume that
the salary difference is 0 euros because
we are not all  Women and men
can be interviewed like a
sample of course even if
there is no difference in the total population there will
certainly be a salary difference in the
sample it could come out, for example
, that a sample
will be drawn and in this sample it will be the
salary difference between women and
men
250 euros but our assumption is
still there is no difference in
salary between women and men in
the population that says p value
and how likely it is
to draw a sample in which the
salary of men and women differs by more than
250 euros although it is  in the
sample there is actually no
difference so we have a
population where there is no
difference now we see a sample in
this sample but we have a
difference and we want to know how
likely it is that we will receive a
salary difference of 250 euros or
more
although in  there is actually
no difference in the population this value
is given by the p value
would you like more information
here please watch my detailed
video on the p value
lets say the value up to four percent that
would mean that it is only four
percent likely that  we
draw a random sample in which the salary is 250
euros or more is the difference between
women and men although there is no difference in the population as a whole
if the ph value is so low
one could of course also say
maybe there is also a
difference in salary between women and
men in the population now
the question is of course  when is the
ph value small enough for
this, the so-called significance
level is introduced the significance level
is always determined before the
examination and must not be
changed afterwards in order to still get the
desired statement to ensure a
certain comparability
sets the significant
level  mostly at 5 or one percent
therefore at a significant level of
less than one percent one speaks of
highly significant at less than five
percent at significant and at greater
than 5 percent of not significant which
means that we now have a ph value
that is less than
percent are usually just
hypo  have rejected thesis how a p
value is greater than five percent keep for
the new thesis so what interests
you at the end of the hypothesis test
is whether a new
hypothesis is kept or rejected
let’s look at it again in
the different process steps
so  First of all, you have to
determine your significance level, which
is usually 5 percent or 1 percent.
Then you have to use a
hypothesis test to calculate the p value.
Did you do that, check whether the p value is
greater than or smaller than the specified significance
level  private is
greater than the specified significance
level, the new hypothesis is
retained if the ph value is less than
the specified significance level,
the new hypothesis is rejected as said
you can never reject 1 0 hypotheses with 100
percent certainty
but only with a certain
probability  there are still
different types of errors to which we
now k
Because of the sample selection, it can
happen that the alternative
hypothesis is accidentally confirmed. There
really is no difference,
so the null hypothesis applies. Conversely
, the result of hypotheses tests can
also be that there is no difference
, so the new hypothesis actually applies,
but the  alternative
hypothesis was is in the first case
one speaks of the so-called alpha error or
first hard error if the alternative
hypothesis is accepted although the
null hypothesis applies in the second case
one speaks of peter error or form
error of the so-called second type if
the null hypothesis is retained
although the alternative  hypothesis applies
this can be seen again in this
table
it can either be that the null
hypothesis was true and we
decide in favor of the new hypothesis
or that the null hypothesis was true and
we decide against the new thesis
then we make a mistake  first has
or the zero hyp  othesis is wrong and
we opt for the new thesis
then we make a mistake of the second kind
would of course be correct if the zero
hypothesis is wrong and we decide
against the new hypothesis like this and
now you probably want to know
where to find the hypotheses and the hypotheses
test  classified in the research process
so let's
take a look at it again at a glance to calculate a hypothesis test
you have to define a
topic with the help of the topic you can then
write a question that we can write based
on the question
then a precisely formulated hypothesis
about the population  are derived based
on the hypothesis,
a suitable hypothesis test is then
sought that checks the assertion have you found a
suitable hypothesis test
you then need your survey data
and together with the survey data and
a hypothesis test you can then come to your
conclusion
I hope the video has  you like  n
if you want to be informed you
will soon have a new video from me
just subscribe to the channel and click
on the blade if you do
n't know datatec yet just visit date up
de there you will find great tutorials and
you can evaluate your data directly online
and with it  see you
next time